[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv 78
nouvelle édition du 78 tours émission
dédiée à vos loisirs à dans les yvelines
nous allons parler patrimoine
gastronomie activités sorti ce mois-ci
avec vous justin et bixente bonjour à
tous les deux jours vous êtes allé
tester en équipe les différents escape
game du secteur exactement il a à peu
près une dizaine il faut le savoir dans
les yvelines et justement on a découvert
deux avec bixente il faut savoir qu'on a
avec eu plusieurs aventures on a dû
s'évader de prison n'avait qu on a été
plongé dans une affaire de poison au
xviie siècle et sachant que normalement
c'est par équipes de trois à six joueurs
et qu'on était que dedans faudra être
indulgent avec nous on verra ça au cours
de 78 tours mais tout d'abord vous
découvrirez aussi les trésors du centre
national est du cinéma à bois d'arcy ont
conservons restaure également le
patrimoine du 7e art français sur un
site insolite il s'agit d'un ancien fort
construit en 1870 après l'invasion des
crues siens plaisir des yeux plaisir des
papilles gustatives également à suivre
nous allons vous présenter un foot rock
original baptisé happy trucks et qui
propose des pâtisseries maison 100%
américaine et puis nous recevrons aussi
en plateau des influenceurs ils comptent
des milliers d'abonnés sur leurs réseaux
ils sont dorénavant des ambassadeurs du
département le conseil départemental a
décidé de miser sur eux pour promouvoir
ses actions et puis le défi du mois vous
le savez depuis le début de cette
émission les équipes de tv 60,18
s'affrontent un de manière ludique en
effet lancer de hache escalade ce mois
ci ce sera elle sur les pistes de carte
du circuit beltoise à trappes
on débute donc avec quelques douceurs
depuis juillet des gourmandises 100%
maison 100% américaine sont préparées
elles sont à distribuer dans un petit
truc c'est un nicolas d'andric et les a
testées pour nous bonjour j'aimerai
connaitre voulons j'ai fondé ma fille
trek en décembre dernier voilà c'est un
fou trucks de patrie américaine tout et
ce en poussant fait-maison laboratoire
je suis pâtir de métier et diplômés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va avoir le clic est
fourrée au nutella alors ça c'est la
grosse vente d'habits trucks le cookie
forever de cacahuètes a aussi son petit
public le cookie classique aux pépites
de chocolat là on a le groupe i le
muffin la touche au coq et fourrure
était là aujourd'hui la brioche à la
cannelle nous avons là le de 9,9
secondes devant foutraque habitera que
c'est le grâce à la vie parce que j'ai
envie d'être transparente avec mes
clients et que c'est une petite phrase
humoristique pour mes emplacement pour
savoir où vous retrouvez le mieux ce
monsieur sur les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'en fait c'est super aléatoire et
sinon je suis privatisable pour les
entreprises publiques et privées et pour
les particuliers
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans l'atelier des
petits trucs c'est ici que je
confectionne tous les gâteaux
[Musique]
c'est un muffin là pour aujourd'hui
c'est une base chocolat cacao et
et là du coup ils sont fournis étaient
là et je vais les décors et c'est tout
mais matières premières poudre d'amande
les noix tous les chocolats nutella
taiseux farine le lait sucre glace
sucres
et sucreries voilà
car la pâte à la défaite hier soir alors
opposé cette nuit et j'ai façonné du
coup ce matin et j'essaie de les cuire à
la dernière minute au plus proche de
partir pour qu'ils soient le plus frais
possible il ya chocolat chocolat c'est
le sucre
citron l'albanie
[Musique]
il y aura une édition spéciale avec des
cordes pour pour noël je vais faire
avec un nappage chocolat et orange je
vais faire sucrer cannelle je vais faire
aussi le vanni il y a
je vais faire pain d'épicés des choses
comme ça vraiment pas qu'ils reflètent
noël
[Musique]
et
nous sommes unanimes le gras c'est la
vie hein c'est la devise est on
l'adoptent par contre vous avez une
réflexion très juste justin tout à
l'heure rien qu'en regardant le sujet on
attrape le diabète c'est ça parce qu'on
irait bien goûter à peu près tout pour
être tout à fait honnête on a goûté
quand même un petit peu puisque nicolas
qui n'est pas là en plateau nous en a
ramené un petit échantillon merci
d'ailleurs à la responsable de ce happy
trucks on va changer d'univers avec un
site qui n'ouvre pas souvent ses portes
au grand public c'est le centre national
du cinéma c'est à bois d'arcy nous a
reçus le temps donc d'une visite guidée
cet ancien ancien fort abrite des
trésors du patrimoine français c'est
vous justin qui vous y êtes rendus
[Musique]
cette semaine je me trouve au centre
national du cinéma et de l'image animée
implanté dans l'ancienne batterie de
bois d'arcy bâtiments militaires du 19e
siècle ici elle est filmé des lumières
la bande de renault ou encore les pimms
d'agnès varda un million cent mille
boîtes 140 mille oeuvres sont conservés
au cnc et on va aller à voir béatrice de
passe trè directrice des collections
pour nous expliquer justement leur
conservation
le principe de la conservation des films
c'est de garantir une température
constante et une hygrométrie également
constante donc on va surveiller
j'aurais ni 365 jours sur 365 jours
et bien la température à l'intérieur des
magasins et en même temps le taux
d'hygrométrie kylie a également dans les
différentes les différentes pièces
aération des des espaces aération du
film à l'intérieur de la de la boîte est
comme ça les films peuvent avoir une vie
qu'on estime aujourd'hui
sur les supports modernes en polyester
d'à peu près 300 ans pour la pellicule
noir et blanc ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'un disque dur numérique
on va aller au laboratoire pour voir un
petit peu les traitements que l'on
opère sur les films pour les sauver les
restaurer
[Musique]
on
prend en charge la restauration des
films des films anciens alors très
anciens on a restauré des négatifs
lumière fait pour l'exposition
universelle de 1900 nous des films des
années 20 où des années 60
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler les
différentes étapes brièvement justement
de restauration alors en numérique oui
la jarretière d'abord scanner de canal
chine c'est à dire transformer une image
argentique en fichier numérique car
chaque photographe être un fichier la
bobine a été nettoyée avant d'être
d'être scannées les scanner et puis va y
avoir le process de restauration puis le
process d'étalonnage je vous propose à
présent d'aller découvrir un trésor
conserver ici elle l'écran d'épinglés un
objet d'art créée par alexandre alexiev
éclair parker suivez-moi
[Musique]
la 500 1000 et pain qui sont
relativement à ces grosses en fait
donc il est assez lourd il fait plus de
150 kilos c'est pas les épargnes lensois
qui font qu'ils font l'image c'est
l'ombre portée de chaque époque sur la
surface blanche qui par une
multiplication à de plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'épinglettes créer cette
image et les contrastes qui vont avec
qui on a toutes les nuances de gris
possibles et imaginables
on peut faire des très très beau
dégrader avec cette technique et on s'en
lasse pas et après on prend deux ans
prend des photos et donc avec deux
condamnations voilà voilà on prend une
photo à chaque fois ou deux plus tôt
puisque en général si on tourne à 24
images seconde
[Musique]
c'est assez impressionnant cette
technique dévoilée à la fin on vous
attend vous a présenté donc ceci du cnc
qui ouvre ses portes souvent au moment
des journées du patrimoine si vous
voulez vous y rendre sur place deux
invités nous ont rejoint un plateau à
présent puisque le département des
yvelines a décidé de communiquer
autrement il a lancé son premier
programme d'influenceurs à l'institution
a pour cela fait appel à une agence de
communication patriat go bonjour à
karine vous en est la responsable la
fondatrice et puis vous êtes venus
accompagner avec l'une des influences de
ce qui rejoint ce programme manuela
bonjour à vous et connu plus tôt sous le
pseudo de poulettes ce n'est la voilà
sur instagram d'ailleurs si vous voulez
les rejoindre les retrouver puisque vous
êtes aussi influent ce on a noté voilà
les les noms volées pseudo un stade pour
vous retrouver c'est assez novateur
quand même comme démarche pourquoi ce
partenariat avec une institution comme
le département alors en fait le
département ont contacté l'agent ce
papagayo pour créer le premier programme
influenceurs du département puisque
l'agencé une grosse expertise sur le
département ce qu'on a fait plusieurs
actions auparavant avec les commerces et
puis les influenceurs du 78 et le
département cherche à avoir de nouveaux
leaders d'opinion des personnes qui
allaient prendre la parole et ils ont
choisi le canal de l' influence et donc
ils m'ont demandé à lagence de créer le
premier programme influenceurs du
département donc aujourd'hui notre poule
d'influenceurs à
en fait va représenter les actions du
département pour parler à leurs
communautés et donc faire connaître les
actions du département que soient les
actions du rhône mentale culturel
familial ou encore sur les pans de
l'éducation sous le hashtag 178 soulage
tag team 78 puis on peut retrouver aussi
toutes les actions sur le compte
instagram du département c'est les
yvelines il y en a huit des influenceurs
influence euse puisque c'est mixte 1
comme comme profession et dont vous
justement pourquoi avoir rejoint ce ce
dispositif qu'est ce qui vous a séduit
dans cette idée alors déjà représenté ce
que fait le département je suis
yvelinoise je suis né vili noise je n'ai
pas quitté le département voilà depuis
depuis que je suis née je suis très
attaché et je pense que le c'est un
petit peu le confinement qui est un
petit peu déclenché qui a augmenté cette
envie de montrer ce qui se passe à
proximité de valoriser vraiment les
actions l'exaction proches donc c'est
vrai que je parle beaucoup de ce qui se
passe au niveau national et de ce qui se
passe au niveau culturel à paris parce
que c'est moi là un petit peu notre
notre
la facilité pour nous mais de plus en
plus je valorise les yvelines et j'aime
cet axe est la communauté suit est très
très attentive à ça ils recommencent à
fonctionner ce que c'est le département
qui passent des commandes ou est ce que
sont les influenceurs influent feu selon
leur sensibilité qui proposait des
sujets qui teste alors en fait le
département a quand on nous a présenté
en fin quand il souhaitait créer le
programme a team 78 c'est en fait à un
groupe projet au sein du département
c'est plusieurs personnes qui auraient
présente sur l'environnement la culture
qui ont qui ont souhaité apporter
l'influencent donc en fait on avait un
cahier des charges avec par exemple la
culture l'environnement et par rapport
aux actions du département nous l'aura
proposé de mettre en place des
événements dédiés pour qu'en fait les
influenceurs puissent aussi avoir du
contenu a présenté sur le compte
instagram c'est à dire qu'en fait on
événement si alizée un petit peu aussi
les actions pour qu'on puisse en parler
et que c'est un côté un peu aussi
pédagogique est aussi visuelle pour les
communautés mais donc c'est des
appartements qu'à fixer à l'est sujet il
doit apprendre à créer des événements
autour mais on voit quelques images de
lors des événements réalisé il ya eu le
musée maurice denis et les yvelines font
leur cinéma aussi
pour vous pour comment ça c'est
organiser concrètement sur le terrain
comment comment on communique comment on
travaille en tant qu influence euse
quand on doit communiquer autour du
travail du département mais justement
grâce à l'action de karine et de son
équipe le département nous on va prendre
l'exemple de daisy blinn font leur
cinéma c'est une action voilà qui du
coup est très parlante et très visuelle
on a sillonné des petits chemins de des
yvelines en deux chevaux pour rejoindre
des lieux de tournage ou des lieux un
peu emblématique par rapport à des films
qui avaient été soit tourné ici soient
des acteurs qui ont vécu ici et c est
donc là c'est vrai qu'on partage il ya
un lien qui est fait entre le cinéma la
projection qu'on avait eu le soir même
et les yvelines donc en fait chaque
action qu'ils aient un peu de
théâtraliser pour nous permettre de d'en
parler de façon ludique et c'est même
sur des thématiques parfois qu'ils sont
pas forcément ludique mais du coup c'est
le fait de mettre en scène des
événements qui nous permet de qui nous
donne une malle de la matière et puis un
peu de relief aussi sur sur les actions
qui sont menées par le département pour
format s'avoue rénové avons réinventé où
c'est le même format vous utilisez avant
on n'est plus dans l'instantané là je
trouve alors c'est vrai que moi j'aime
bien faire des photos un peu étudiée là
je prends le téléphone je suis plus en
mode story en partageant live ce qu'on
est en train de vivre là les deux
chevaux on avait la tête au vent il
pleuvait en effet tout aval en est
revenu on était on est passés par des
écuries on n'avait qu'une envie c'était
aller de se blottir certains chevaux
étaient ultra attachant donc donc tout
ça on a le téléphone voilà à portée de
bras et ayant filmé en direct et vos
communautés réagissent comme au togo ils
sont très positifs et en fait on se rend
compte que nos communautés ont besoin de
local en fête et de proximité et le fait
de parler de ville ou d'actions qui leur
sont proches et en fait c'est surtout
des actions sur lesquelles eux peuvent
aller où se rendre en bâtissant ils sont
très enclin il adore en fait parce que
ils peuvent le faire et puis c'est leur
département donc une sorte aussi un
petit peu de fierté quand on communique
mai à laon les communautés sont très
très bienveillante moi je le vois sur ma
casquette aussi influents se sait que ma
communauté et adore en fait ce que je
partage avec le département vous êtes
sur le secteur de poids sur jeu balancé
ça est-ce que si je vous demande un
petit conseil un bon plan quelque chose
à partager aux téléspectateurs pour le
coup oui en tant que consommatrice mais
pas seulement en tant qu influence parce
qu'avec le département on est sur des
formats un bon plan qu'est ce que je
peux vous donner bon ben là il ya une
tonne un bon plan c'est parce que
viennent de découvrir il ya un très très
belle exposition qui vient de commencer
au château de versailles qui s'appelle
les animaux du roi est en fait alors
c'est une exposition qu'on peut faire
avec les enfants ou pas mais en
l'occurrence les ateliers qui sont
proposés pour créer son animal voilà en
céramique enfin en argile plutôt avec
les enfants à faire en duo c'est une
très très belle idée là pour les
vacances qui vous ai fait travailler
grand merci beaucoup enfin pour ceux qui
nous suivent sur cette expo qui a lieu à
versailles qu'il y en a 8 ans des
influences l'affluence husky qui
travaillent avec vous ils viennent des
quatre coins du département c'est une
communauté qui est amenée à s'élargir
peut-être même voilà se diversifier
alors ça on verra à la fin le programme
et jusqu'à jusqu'au mois de juin 2022
donc de là avec le département on en
tirera aussi les bilans les chiffres est
ce que ça a bien fonctionné parce que
les communautés ont vraiment bien suivi
de projet jusqu'à la fin et puis après
sera département qui verra s'ils veulent
élargir cette team 78 continuer le
projet mais en tous les cas on fait
vraiment des belles choses et c'est
vraiment rare en fait qu'un département
travaille avec les influenceurs mais
vraiment sur le côté institutionnel et
ne vais pas sur la le tourisme en fait
secrètement on porte vraiment des
projets du département et ça c'est
vraiment un beau enfin c'est un beau
concept qu'on a réalisé pour d'ailleurs
une à leurs questions le prochain la
prochaine action ce sera au tour de la
pmi protection maternelle infantile
exactement ça se passe et comment et
bien en fait on va visiter une pmi à la
pmi de saint germain en laye en fait on
va montrer aux influenceurs bas tout ce
qui est possible de faire dans une pmi
est en fait ça va être de pouvoir en
fait communiquer à leur communauté leur
là que la pmi à l'ue ouvertes à tous
qu'elle est qu'elle est gratuite pour le
grand public et donc en fait on va faire
une visite on va être in situ et tous
les influenceurs participent aux mêmes
événements du coup oui tous les
influenceurs partie vous aime au même
événement après selon les sensibilités
des fois il ya des influenceurs qui sont
plus famille d'autres qui vont être plus
sur l'environnement bah là on va faire
aussi du cas par cas variantes sur la
pmi c'est du cas par cas parce que
toutes les les influenceurs sont pas
forcément par an donc en fait on a qui
ont plutôt raconter l'histoire de la pmi
d'autres qui vont plutôt être sûr des
ateliers de la paix m donc on fait
vraiment du cas par cas et du sur mesure
c'est aussi ça la force de la team 78
vous allez rester encore quelques
minutes avec nous en place tout est ce
que vous êtes amatrice des skins game
ouvrez grand vos oreilles c'est nous qui
allons vous donner quelques bons plans à
présent bixente justin c'est à vous vous
êtes allé et stc ces jeux d'évasion
grandeur nature rappelle qui rappelle le
concept peut être déjà avec vos bixente
oui puisque la plupart ici peut-être
connaissent déjà savent déjà comment ça
se passe le principe est simple vous
choisissez un scénario à partir de là
vous êtes coincé dans une salle et vous
avez une heure pour vous en sortir un
game master est présent et vous
observent depuis son ordinateur pour
vous donner des petits indices en cas de
besoin la communication est essentielle
si vous trouvez vous devez tout tenir au
courant l'équipe des avancées des
nouveaux éléments des clés par exemple
si vous en avez et qu'il ya des corps il
faut leur dire bien sûr ce sera ponctuée
de fouilles de réflexion et de logique
en même temps mais c'est accessible à
tous la preuve on a réussi vous avez
testé lesquels on a testé du coup deux
escape game avec justin s'excite à
poissy engrenage à versailles donc les
scénarios les a fait à deux mais le
nombre idéal bien sûr pour une équipe
c'est 4 en accord avec tous les games
master bien que les équipes peuvent
aller de trois à six personnes vous
savez un métier difficile testé sur vos
heures de travail très exactement jetez
vous pouvez peut-être qu'on commence par
exit la poisse y aller faut savoir que
c'est un établissement qui tient une
ligne conductrice précise 50% de
réussite sur les salles dixit a ouvert
en 2018 par trois salles à poissy et
depuis trois nouvelles salles dont été
créée à saint germain en laye nous avons
fait la salle prison bêta le pitch il
est lié à l'actualité les prisons sont
surchargées de détenus dont la prison de
poissy je laisse à yoann notre game
masters le soin de vous lire la suite
l'état une petite idée toute idée
sympathique pour réduire le nombre de
prisonniers à petit peine dans les
prisons français ils sont dit qu'ils
allaient mettre un nouveau concept de
prison en place les prisons bêta si vous
avez déjà entendu parler ça vous parle
pas
normal c'est top secret ouais c'est cet
homme secret je vous révèle une info
comme ça je m'entends bien avec la
ministre de la justice voit une info en
plus la première est derrière moi ici
même à poissy et c'est après ça que tout
s'emballe et qu'on se retrouve plongé
dans le noir et entre les quatre murs
d'une cellule et bilan malheureusement
on est sortis unither tard c'est un
échec pour celui ci ça c'était avant que
le premier et on a aussi testé donc
engrenage à versailles exactement et
donc on a rencontré laurent brissette
qui est cogérant il a créé sa avec son
frère ils ont ouvert en 2018 aujourd'hui
ils ont quand même cinq scénarios ils
sont basés sur des histoires vraies
certains donc ça met dans l'ambiance est
donc nous on a testé un autre salle qui
était basé sur une histoire vraie aussi
c'est l' affaire des poisons une affaire
d'empoisonnement qui est survenu à
versailles au xviie siècle et donc louis
xiv nous a confié l enquête regarder on
est quelques années en arrière en 1679
tout simplement et donc à cette époque
il ya des empoisonnements la cour de
versailles donc le roi louis xiv et
affaiblit son pouvoir royal est
affaiblie donc il va demander à louis de
la reynie qui est un lieutenant général
de police d'enquêter sur 7 sur cette
affaire donc à ce titre là j'ai reçu une
missive
que vous pouvez lire à toute l'équipe
cente jeter les services notre timing
cette fois on a réussi on est sorti au
bout de 56 minutes félicitations à vous
on est plutôt fier 6 minutes 50 minutes
d'avancé sur le timing et pour le coup
j'ai eu l'impression qu'on avait utilisé
moins d'un disque pour l'autre escape
game mais c'est long mais bon ce qui
excite les points forts c'est le côté
immersif et le fait que le game master
et un rôle un peu particulier on vous en
dira pas plus exactement vous en dit pas
plus mais ça rajoute vraiment beaucoup
et c'est ce que j'ai préféré en fait on
s'y attend pas sinon j'ai beaucoup aimé
aussi d'immersion dans la prison je sais
pas pour toi bixente mais le fait de
commentaire et en cellule vraiment ça
nous plombe ça plonge directement dedans
et pour engrenage à versailles je crois
que c'est le petit coup de coeur de
justin je laisse le soin d'en dire un
peu plus et c'est ça déjà le fait de
savoir que l'histoire a vraiment existé
a vraiment lieu ça ça plonge encore une
fois dans l'ambiance mon coup de coeur
pour le coup c'était les décors chaque
nouveau chaque nouvel élément était
complètement différent se croyait
vraiment l'époque à ce moment là en fait
est en tout cas dans les deux salles il
ya un côté humain en finale parce que
c'est des créneaux de deux heures les
masters s'adapte aux joueurs et prennent
le temps de discuter de débriefer avec
après toujours un petit échange avoué
après puisque vous êtes amatrice des
skins game pardon le dernier vous ayez
fait dans les yvelines les
châteaux de maisons laffitte il me
semble qu'il ya des soirées un peu
thématique un chat email etc il a fait
pendant le fait oui effectivement et
puis en ayant plus une salle en plus
pendant la période d'halloween occasion
de revenir vous allez vous dire est ce
que vous en pensez
quelques autres noms aussi un glorious
et skype vélizy-villacoublay avec des
scénarios basés sur des films des séries
walking dead l'os ton corps django voilà
merci à tous les deux et merci aussi à
nos invités d'être venu aujourd'hui vous
parler de ce programme influenceurs qui
a été mis en place avec le département
des yvelines on va passer à l'ultime
séquence de cette émission
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire je
défie de la rédaction chaque mois vous
le savez les membres de l'équipe
s'affrontent chaque membre de l'équipe
est confronté à un autre cette fois ci
c'était donc à mon tour grâce à vous
merci justin face à patrice carmouze
nous sommes allés cher le circuit
circuit de kart installé à beltoise à
trappes
attention ouais ça c'est du clap c'est
le meilleur club de l'ouest a
rivalisé
patrice vous êtes prêt à relever le défi
de la rédaction bon
on va bien voir déjà le kartman
quelques mois avec éric fournier qui
nous accueillent bonjour là bonjour à
vis actuellement nous recevoir ici sur
notre circuit de deux cartes déjà la
discipline s'adresse à qui est ce que il
faut déjà être bien connaisseurs avant
de s'élancer sur la piste sinon on va
repartir lance pas forcément vous
inquiétez pas tu vas où je vous donner
quelques petits conseils avant de partir
faire surtout que la piste est un tout
petit peu glissante que il y aura
peut-être quelques petits pièges à
éviter mais sinon dans le principe non
c'est vraiment ça s'adresse à tout le
monde puisqu'on peut accueillir des du
public et dès l'âge de 8 ans abattu au
moment où ils ont la taille mais il y
avait un champion dans les yvelines
d'ailleurs qui était très jeune mais il
ya déjà quelques années le climat aura
effectivement toute façon c'est vrai que
dans le kart ça commence de plus en plus
tôt puisque nous on entraîne même des
petits qui sont dans la catégorie minime
et qui ont fait des bons résultats déjà
cette année voilà donc ça fait partie
des activités qu'on propose c'est le
circuit principal il ya deux circuits
c'est ça donc là on va pour la petite la
petite compétition à l'entrepôt à ce que
je crois qu'il ya un petit challenge
entre vous vous allez faire sur la piste
dite compétition mais animations
d'accord a effectivement sinon la n2 une
deuxième piste qui se trouve un petit
peu à un petit peu avant la cause est
arrivée qui est un petit peu plus petit
est là qui est plutôt dédié aux loisirs
animations voilà maintenant aller
s'agissait alors c'est assez paradoxal
à paris on n'est pas
là pour il est pas là pour rigoler je le
dis moi
savourer bien et si on reste comme ça
[Musique]
allait attention tu as fait pour un
challenge sprint a trahi sur trois tours
ok donc christine et patrice despretz
c'est pas tout ce qu'il fallait
je ne peux pas
prendre deux ans cadette de venus
ap
m
de plus
c'est pas qu'on pense que ce sera bon
tous les besoins
la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
félicitations patrice ça fait je suis
parti en dérapage à peu près partout
pourtant ce que patrice a caché son jeu
et sa force qui nous a pas tout dit reza
radan patrice beunard marche allez-y
alors deuxième et puis bah donc du coup
vous allez repartir à la voix incroyable
félicitations patrice merci beaucoup
félicitations s'est passé ce qu'il en
pense
côté jeu partait pas favori
à la cool
à la cool c'est donc patrice qui s'est
imposé voilà désolé pour le suspense
était le premier temps ce fut compliqué
c'était trop de très trop mouillé les
conditions climatiques j'avais pas des
pneus pluie je soupçonne qu'ils aient
une petite connaissance entre eux et
patrice et le gérons tout nous a
accueillis voilà peut-être je ne sais
pas non sans mauvaise foi aucune ma
patrie cela fait à la cool comme me l'a
dit s'est imposée et encore une fois
merci aux responsables du berck à sur le
circuit beltoise nous avoir accueillis
gentiment pendant pendant une bonne
heure pour faire ce petit reportage est
présenté sa discipline mais
malgré tout ce dernier mais quand même
une médaille prochain défi parce qu'il
faut désigner les prochains oui on a
certes elle n'a pas encore pas ça c'est
vrai que je pensais le prochain face à
melanie mal à nice 1 à bercy on n'a pas
fait encore décide travers celui-ci plis
non on vous trouvera sinon quelque chose
78 on va se refermer pour ce mois ci le
mois prochain en édition spéciale fin
d'année on reviendra sur l'actualité de
la semaine ce sera un petit peu sérieux
mais pas uniquement toujours de la bonne
humeur et puis la découverte de notre
patrimoine des richesses du département
des yvelines donc votre test et défie ce
sera peut-être pour le mois de janvier
plutôt voilà avec l'émission de fin
décembre merci à vous deux merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve très vite sur
tv 78
[Musique]